les quatre principaux chefs historiques
du mouvement terroriste action directe
arrêtés dans une ferme dans le
département du loiret préparait un
enlèvement des armes de l'argent et des
documents retrouvés sur place par les
policiers
les ministres des finances des six pays
les plus riches en l'absence volontaire
de l'italie adopte à paris une
résolution pour stabiliser les taux de
change au niveau actuel porte à deux
deuxièmes avec daniel cazals avec le
record du monde du 200 m en salle battu
par le français bruno marie rose
aujourd'hui dimanche 22 février 1987
nouvelle journée de détention pour les
otages français au liban marcel fontaine
et marcel carton
jean paul kauffmann et jean louis
normandin d'antenne 2 n'ont toujours pas
été libérés
bonsoir jean marc rouillan nathalie
ménigon joëlle aubron
georges cipriani arrêté hier soir vers
21h sont considérés comme les chefs
historiques du mouvement terroriste
action directe cette arrestation groupe
et sans effusion de sang est un succès
pour la police tout entière et pas
seulement pour les hommes de l'unité
d'élite qui sont intervenus hier sur la
commune de vitry aux loges dans le
département du loiret les quatre
militants d'action directe se trouvait
dans une ferme isolée
voici avec emmanuel vanier jean
corneille et dominique thiel les
conditions reconstitué de l'opération
policière
voici la ferme où jean marc rouillan et
nathalie ménigon les deux chefs
historiques d'action directe
ainsi que joëlle aubron et georges
cipriani ont été arrêtés hier soir une
opération parfaitement menée par les
policiers du raid recherche assistance
intervention dissuasion avec à leur tête
le commissaire ange mancini
il ya là plus de 50 policiers du raid et
30 membres des renseignements généraux
hier dans la journée il cerne la ferme
et identifie formellement nathalie
ménigon à 20h55 l'assaut dans la ferme
la surprise est totale de membres
d'action directe tente de s'enfuir par
les fenêtres les policiers tirent en
l'air les quatre terroristes sont
arrêtés l' enquête était en cours depuis
plusieurs semaines une prime d'un
million de francs avait été offerte à
tout informateur vendredi les policiers
recouper deux informations capitales
il mettait alors en place leur
dispositif autour de la plante des
terroristes lors de la perquisition les
policiers ont découvert un véritable
arsenal un fusil d'assaut 30 kg
d'explosif 80 détonateur et du matériel
des coûts très sophistiqué de nombreux
documents ont également été saisis
notamment des listes de personnalités à
enlever ou à tuer et surtout des
policiers ont découvert l'original de la
revendication de l'assassinât de georges
besse l'ancien président directeur
général de renault a battu en novembre
dernier à paris par deux femmes se
réclamant d'action directe
les policiers vont maintenant épluché
ses documents et analyser les armes et
les munitions
ils vont notamment les comparer aux
douilles retrouvées près du corps de
georges besse dans la ferme six pièces
l'une d'elles a été aménagé en prison
populaire les enquêteurs pensent qu
action directe projetaient d'enlever
prochainement une personnalité
importante dans le village c'est la
stupéfaction depuis trois ans on
connaissait bien rouillan et ménigon qui
se faisait appeler nadine des voisins
tranquille est plutôt sympathique dit on
vous voyez le plus souvent c'était une
fille qui venait ici trop fort semaine
presque trois semaines au ravitaillement
de chercher du lait mais des fois et
venez pour hier le lait nous voulons
dire bonjour et puis des fois vous devez
garder la grammaire 88 ans la survie et
accorde le travail était sympathique
vraiment gentille vraiment hier dans ce
petit village de l'orléanais c'est donc
une longue traque de plus de 4 ans qui a
pris fin avec les policiers des
renseignements généraux ce sont les
enquêteurs du srpj de versailles service
régional de police judiciaire qui ont
participé au travail de recoupement
d'observation d'analysé des informations
recueillies c'est à versailles qui ont
été conduits les quatre personnes
arrêtées hier soir jean marc rouillan
étant demeuré un peu plus longtemps avec
les policiers les magistrats pour la
perquisition effectuée dans la ferme à
versailles pour antenne de thierry
calmette
trois des membres du noyau dur d'action
directe sont interrogés ici à versailles
depuis tôt ce matin jean marc rouillan
rester à vitry pour assister légalement
aux perquisitions devraient rejoindre
dans la soirée mais pas lui mais niveau
joëlle aubron et georges cipriani
pas moins de cinq services de police
participe talent enquête la police
judiciaire de versailles
la sixième section de la pj de paris le
raid
la brigade criminelle et les
renseignements généraux ce sont eux avec
claude bardon la direction centrale qui
ont eu les tuyaux qui ont permis
d'arrêter le couple de terroristes une
enquête classique avec filature planque
indicateurs presque une routine
si les terroristes sont aujourd'hui
interrogé à versailles c'est qu'ils
doivent y répondre de la tentative
d'assassinât sur 10 branagh en avril 86
et du meurtre du général audran en 85
d'autres commissions rogatoires les
attendent au quai des orfèvres à paris
il s'agira alors de l'assassinât de
georges besse i si la police a mis en
place un dispositif de sécurité renforcé
tous les membres d'action directe ne
sont pas encore sous les verrous depuis
hier ce sont donc tous les responsables
présumés d'action directe qui sont en
prison jean marc rouillan nathalie
ménigon joëlle aubron georges cipriani
suivant ainsi régis schleicher détenu
est accusé du meurtre de deux policiers
avenue trudaine c'est donc un coup très
sévère porté aux mouvements d'action
directe
né il y a huit ans mouvement hétérogène
qui n'a cessé de dériver vers les
actions les plus sanglantes en france en
liaison avec d'autres groupes
terroristes européen
l'histoire d'action directe résumé est
expliquée par hervé brusini et dominique
tierces de la publicité pour action
directe en plein paris nous sommes en
décembre 81 rouillan ménigon et tous les
membres du groupe sont dans les rues ils
ont été amnistiés quelques mois plus tôt
dans les immeubles insalubres du xviiie
arrondissement
ils jouent les assistantes sociales
défendre la cause des immigrés parle à
la télé accès direct au grand jour cela
ne durera pas longtemps et chef
historique viennent de la clandestinité
ils vont y retourner
jean marc rouillan d'abord à 18 ans il
se donne le nom guerre ce basse et
disparaît pour militer au sein du gari
le groupe d'action révolutionnaire
internationaliste avec le gari il signe
ses premiers attentats dans le sud ouest
de la france
c'est l'époque de la solidarité avec les
espagnols antifranquistes nathalie
ménigon elle vient de l'extrême gauche
l'ancien employé de banque a choisi les
rangs de l'autonomie barres de fer
cocktails molotov casque de motard
l'option violence comme projet politique
en 79 ménigon et rouillan fonds d'action
directe
ce couple va devenir l'obsession des
policiers quatre ou cinq personnes
composent le groupe au début mais très
vite dans leur sillage elle entraîne une
centaine de sympathisants action
symbolique les cibles ministère et
magasins de luxe brusque coup d'arrêt en
81 la rue pergolèse nathalie ménigon et
ceinturé par les hommes des
renseignements généraux
elles viennent vider son chargeur sur
les policiers en hurlant je suis action
directe à ses côtés rouillan lui aussi
est arrêté tous les deux resteront un an
sous les verrous avant de profiter de la
loi d'aministie 1982 dans ce parking
les policiers découvrent un arsenal
action directe s'est réarmé fusil à
pompe et pistolets mitrailleurs grenades
offensives
c'est joëlle aubron qui les a mis sur
cette piste semble vouloir elle est
arrêté et relâché dix huit mois plus
tard
joëlle aubron la fille de bonne famille
une proche du couple
rouillan ménigon à eux trois ils forment
le noyau dur d'action directe ils
commettront plusieurs braquages avec
leurs complices
cipriani ils sont l'essentiel de la
branche internationaliste d'action
directe 1984 les débuts de l'euro
terrorisme vaste offensive contre l'otan
plusieurs bombes sont placés sur le
réseau les eaux du pacte atlantique les
policiers au sentiment que les
clandestins sont décidément
insaisissable et ce qu'il redoutait
annoncé au grand jour le mariage entre
les français d'action directe et les
allemands de la fraction armée rouge
mais aussi
les belges des cellules communistes
combattantes les ccc
85 nouvelle escalade de la violence les
assassinats 1 comme audran l'ingénieur
général de l'armement deux tentatives
ensuite contre le général blanc d'un
contrôleur des armées et guy branagh
vice président du patronat
enfin georges besse le pdg de renault
abattu devant son domicile principaux
suspects joëlle aubron nathalie ménigon
dans le texte de revendication de cet
attentat action directe annoncé ses
prochaines cibles
les sections spéciales chargées de la
lutte antiterroriste aujourd'hui c'est
devant tel que devront s'expliquer
rouillan et ses complices efficacité
policière dans cette ria mais on reste
quand même relativement prudent dans le
milieu policier
oui et il était grand temps on n'ose
imaginer la suite du scénario
si les policiers n'avaient pas
brutalement interrompue hier soir le
délire de rouillan et sa bande
une personnalité qui pourrait être
robert hersant mais il y avait d'autres
noms sur la liste kidnappée séquestrée
dans cette dérisoire prison populaire et
puis la parodie de jugement devant les
pseudos magistrat de ce que le chef
d'action directe appelle pompeusement le
tribunal du peuple chapitre suivant le
marchandage le condamné aurait été
proposé comme monnaie d'échangé contre
la libération de régis les chairs
principal inculpé dans la sphère de
l'avenue trudaine et autres chefs
historiques du groupe
un groupe qui totalise aujourd'hui une
bonne quarantaine de militants sous les
verrous ces deux composantes la branche
nationaliste dirigé par le lyonnais
andré olivier et la branche
internationaliste de rouillan et munich
ont décapité son allié principal les
cellules communistes combattantes belge
de pierre carette réduite à néant
apparemment une véritable déroute les
charges qui pèsent sur les uns et les
autres semblent d'ores et déjà
suffisante pour motiver de sévère
condamnation devant la cour d'assises
spéciale on ne peut pour autant affirmer
que tout danger soit écarté
max frérot l'artificier lyonnais court
toujours les deux jeunes femmes repérer
par des témoins de l'assassinât de
georges besse n'était peut-être pas
nathalie ménigon et joëlle aubron les
réserves inconnu de la petite armée
d'action directe sont sans doute maigre
mais composées de soldats perdus
fanatisés
est prêt à tout l'arrestation des quatre
d'action directe c'est un succès on s'en
réjouit ainsi de multiples réactions ce
sens ont été communiquées aujourd'hui
aussi bien de la part de certains
syndicats de police qu de formation
politique à gauche ou à droite le chef
de l'état le premier ministre et le
ministre de l'intérieur ont envoyé des
télégrammes ou policier télégramme de
jacques chirac un charles pasqua et
robert pandraud transmettait mes
félicitations les plus chaleureuses à
tous les fonctionnaires de la police
nationale qui ont contribué aux
arrestations message de françois
mitterrand à jacques chirac
ce remarquable succès est un
encouragement pour poursuivre et
intensifier la lutte que l'état doit
mener sans défaillance afin d'écarter
les menaces terroristes qui
malheureusement continuent de peser sur
notre pays sur la démocratie et sur nos
libertés
charles pasqua et robert pandraud
avaient de leur côté adressé dans la
nuit leurs vives félicitations aux
policiers
on ne peut manquer de constater une
coïncidence l'arrestation des
responsables d'action directe est
intervenue quelques heures avant le
procès de georges ibrahim abdallah
présumé chef des fractions armées
révolutionnaires libanaises les farl
auteur de plusieurs attentats en france
autour du palais de justice de paris
des mesures de sécurité depuis plusieurs
jours près sévères ont été décidés
contrôle des identités des personnes
surveillance des bâtiments
plusieurs compagnies de crs ont été
appelés en renfort les conditions de
circulation et de stationnement autour
du palais de justice seront très limités
pendant toute la durée du procès c'est à
dire plus d'une semaine première
audience demain le tribunal sera
composée de magistrats professionnels
il n'y aura pas de jurés populaires
explications paul le faire la cour
d'assises spéciale a été créée par la
loi du 21 juillet 1982 elle remplaçait
les tribunaux militaires et avait pour
objectif de juger les dossiers
d'espionnage ou d' atteinte à la défense
nationale modifié en septembre et
décembre 86 ce tribunal a maintenant
compétence pour juger les crimes de
terrorisme
la cour d'assises spéciale qui siège au
palais de justice de paris est unique et
jugent tous les dossiers d'actes de
terrorisme commis en france
elle est composée de sept magistrats
signé à chaque fois au sein de la cour
d'appel de paris par monsieur pierre
drai le premier président aucun d'eux ne
peut être récusés par l'accusation ou la
défense
les décisions sont prises à la majorité
simple soit un minimum de quatre voix
sur 7
par mesure de sécurité l'identité de ces
magistrats n'a pas été révélé et il est
interdit de les photographier ou de les
filmer dans la salle d'audience seuls
sont donc connues pour l'instant
le président de la cour d'assises
monsieur maurice colons et l'avocat
général monsieur pierre bachelin tous
font l'objet d'une protection rapprochée
depuis leur désignation
aucun magistrat ne s'est récusé pour
faire partie de cette cour d'assises
spéciale dont le procès abdallah est le
premier dossier
georges ibrahim abdallah peut refuser
d'assister à son procès le président de
la cour d'assises alors le choix entre
décidé de le faire comparaître de force
on ne le fait jamais
ou pour suivre les débats en en
communiquant chaque jour le contenu à
l'accusé dans sa cellule par le greffier
de la cour d'assises dans ce dernier cas
l'avocat de la défense en l'occurrence
jacques vergès seraient réduits au
silence
à l'issue de la réunion tenue au
ministère des finances au palais du
louvre paris les ministres des finances
et gouverneurs des banques centrales des
six pays les plus riches sont convenus
de coopérer étroitement pour promouvoir
la stabilité des taux de change autour
des niveaux actuels c'est le texte du
communiqué ils étaient six car les
italiens n'avaient pas apprécié la
réunion de samedi ne voulait pas être
mis devant le fait accompli
ils se sont donc retiré plusieurs
engagements ont été pris par les
représentants des six pays et
collectivement ils ont annoncé trois
grandes décisions première décision
stabiliser les monnaies à leurs cours
actuels seconds accroître les efforts de
coordination économique troisième mise
en place d'indicateurs pour étudier les
perspectives économiques dans chaque
pays les américains ont pris
l'engagement de refuser le
protectionnisme et de poursuivre leurs
efforts pour réduire leurs déficits
budgétaires
considéré comme un des principaux
fauteurs de troubles financiers dans le
monde
les japonais annonce des mesures pour
relancer leur consommation intérieure à
partir du printemps et les allemands
pour les mêmes raisons vont amplifier
les allégements fiscaux déjà privé pour
edouard balladur ce sont des engagements
qui vont être très importants pour les
monnaies ils vont effectivement
permettre une plus grand calme sur le
marché des changes
et c'est indispensable la france est un
pays qui importe la plus grande partie
de ces matières premières elle a donc
autant et parfois plus que d'autres
besoin d'une stabilité monétaire faute
de quoi ses importations
son commerce extérieur son budget sont
perturbées par des phénomènes extérieurs
je me réjouis que nos partenaires et
nous mêmes ayons pu décider d'une part
d'harmoniser nos politiques économiques
et d'autre part de faire en sorte que
soient stabilisés
les taux actuels des changes entre les
grandes monnaies et je me réjouis que
cela se soit produit à paris si aucun
accord important à mes yeux il est
important pour l'avenir on pourra juger
cet avenir à quel moment on en jugera
tout au long des mois qui vont venir
je crois que une stabilité monétaire
plus grande va nous permettre de
développer notre commerce international
dans de meilleures conditions
vous savez l'importance que cela revêt
pour nous français et puis le ministre
des finances a confirmé la poursuite de
sa politique visant à baisser les impôts
et à diminuer le déficit du budget ainsi
qu à libéraliser l'économie française il
reste à régler le différend avec les
italiens mais surtout à confronter les
engagements pris par les six pays à
l'épreuve des marchés des changes
commentaires philippe sassier en
définitive ce sont les marchés des
changes qui à partir de demain jugeront
du contenu de cet accord en tout cas en
reconnaissant que les nouvelles et
fortes variations des monnaies pourrait
compromettre la croissance et les
équilibres économiques des 30 pays
occidentaux les ministres des finances
qui était à paris ont clairement reconnu
qu'il fallait stabiliser le dollar
autour de ses niveaux actuels
et pour y arriver il fallait coopérer
étroitement cette coopération
internationale a déjà fort bien
fonctionné
lorsqu'en septembre 1985 on avait décidé
de faire baisser le dollar
dire qu'à cette époque la volonté
politique internationale coïncidé avec
les tendances du marché
aujourd'hui il en va peut-être un petit
peu différemment il ya un risque de
devoir s'affronter la volonté politique
des nations et les forces de la
spéculation
n'oublions pas que chaque jour les
transactions financières mondiales
représente plus de 1000 milliards de
francs en tout cas un des points les
plus positifs de cette réunion de paris
et d'avoir montré il fallait coordonner
les politiques économiques au liban
l'armée syrienne a commencé à se
déployer en début de soirée dans les
rues du secteur à majorité musulmane de
beyrouth
les syriens ont pris position autour de
l'aéroport de la capitale libanaise de
beyrouth correspondances téléphoniques
de samy quête de l' agence france-presse
attentat à jérusalem aux abords de la
vieille ville l'engin explosif était
dirigée contre un stationnement d'une
unité de la police israélienne il y a
dix huit blessés
arrestation en afrique du sud d'un
journaliste de l'agencé france presse il
était arrêté au trans kayes et puis à
johannesburg les parents de pierre andré
albertini cauet soupe coopérants
français emprisonnés en afrique du sud
attendent toujours à l'aéroport un visa
d'entrée premier vol de l'a 320 le petit
dernier de la famille airbus c'était ce
matin à toulouse blagnac l'appareil a
été testé à 13 villes mètres d'altitude
dans de bonnes conditions
météorologiques commentaires laurent
bouvier
9h34 ce matin dans les brumes de la
banlieue toulousaine l'a320 s'élance sur
la piste premier décollage pour un
premier vol une semaine après son
baptême officiel par le prince charles
et lady diana et décollages impeccable
suivie d'un vol de trois heures et demie
pendant lequel tout le domaine de vol a
été testée vitesse de 900 km heure
altitude de 12000 à 13 milles mètres et
contrôle des commandes électriques
considérée comme la nouveauté des
nouveautés sur un avion civil
tout semble s'être bien passé après un
passage à quelques mètres au-dessus de
la piste l'avion s'est posé en souplesse
à 12h52 pour l'équipage décès composé de
français et d'allemand et d'anglais
c'est je cite l'avion le plus doux le
plus agréable et le plus silencieux
la réussite de ce premier vol va
permettre d'attaquer très vite la suite
du programme d'essais et de
certification prochain décollage donc
trois jours pour cet avion déjà
commandés ferme ou en option à 430 nm
exemplaires dont les premiers devront
être livrés à partir de mars 1988 à air
france et à la british calédoniennes le
peintre et créateur andy warhol est
décédé d'une crise cardiaque à new york
la nuit dernière andy warhol était âgé
de 58 ans il venait de subir une
opération de la vésicule biliaire andy
warhol était considéré comme le roi du
pop art commentaires georges big ben
warhol phénomène artistique du xxème
siècle touche à tout de génie il
promenait sa chevelure blonde et sa
silhouette frêle dans l'environnement
moderne et projeter son imagination
hyper réaliste sur les objets les plus
usuelles il devint célèbre en
transformant en oeuvre d'art les
étiquettes des boîtes de soupe campbell
et autres produits courants andy warhol
était aussi musicien d'avant garde en
matière de peinture il inventa les
exposition vivante les fameux happening
et de marilyn monroe à elizabeth taylor
hillbrow ça dépend très audacieux aux
couleurs crues en partant de photos le
cinéma le tente pas également
il réalisa les films dont certains comme
flèche furent considérés comme
pornographique provocateur pour ses
détracteurs génie précurseur pour ses
admirateurs
il est sûr en tout cas que les
publicitaires d'aujourd'hui lui doivent
tous beaucoup sport stades de deuxième
pour soir daniel c'est un deuxième bon
supporter 10 conseil a déjà caristan est
maintenant bruno marie rose avec un
titre dans quand même du monde
oui oui est d'autant plus inattendu ce
record du monde du 200 m que bruno marie
rose avait déçu car dans les séries du
60 m ils avaient été éliminés président
a prématurément et bien il a pris une
revanche formidable en remportant la
médaille d'or du 200 m
les français ont emporté au total trois
médailles d'or une médaille d'argent
deux médailles de bronze de voyons ça en
compagnie de gilles cozanet c'est à
nîmes rivaux est à l'extérieur au
couloir numéro 6 1 vos avantages pour
lui parce qu'il n'a plus ainsi qu'une
petite moitié de premier virage a
effectué 150 premiers mètres très rapide
que cloud 9 le soviétique à la 4e'
régissent le britannique à la ligne 5
parcours à la même vitesse mais c'est
dans la ligne d'arrivée que marie rose
produit une nouvelle accélération
puissante impressionnante
ma seconde 36 nouveaux records du monde
15 centièmes de mieux que l'ancien
record du monde de stéphane othily un
gouffre sur une distance aussi courte
un temps plus que le titre qui place
bruno marie rose parmi l'élite des
meilleurs skateurs du monde âgé de 22
ans doté d'un gabarit impressionnant 1 m
93 83 kg il ira dès vendredi prochain à
new york aux championnats des états unis
défier les sprinteurs américains sur
leurs terres un premier grand
rendez-vous avant les championnats du
monde
le champion d'europe surprise c'est
serge hélan le recordman de france du
triple saut 17 mètres 15 à son deuxième
essai un record de france amélioré de 35
cm et pour lui aussi c'est un gouffre
mais surtout ayant abattu deux
compétiteurs d'envergure le bulgare
markov et le soviétique moutien co2
ancien recordman d'europe
serge hélan c'est aussi comme marie rose
un espoir de 22 ans est un symbole de la
combativité de certains athlètes
français plus attendus en revanche la
victoire de thierry vigneron dans le
concours du saut à la perche
c'est son troisième titre de champion
d'europe en salle ils le gagnent en
égalant son record de france 1 m 85 un
record qu'il doit maintenant partager
avec ferencz albert lui aussi sa m 85
mais seulement 2e du concours
c'était à liévin d'où vient votre dada
c'est le tennis le tennis ou et bien à
indian wells qui est un tournoi qui se
déroule aux états unis re l'absence de
l'un d'elles ce sont les deuxième et
troisième meilleurs joueurs mondiaux qui
vont se rencontrer ce soir même en
finale puisque hedberg le suédois
vainqueur du bilan d'air en demi-finale
rencontre becker l'allemand vainqueur de
yannick noah en demi finale cela au
meilleur des cinq manches
en tennis de table et bien au champion
du monde une défaite des françaises
devant les suédoises les françaises ne
peuvent pas espérer mieux qu'une
neuvième place car elles sont dans la
catégorie 9e 16e tout comme les délais
une petite chinoise
oui oui qui a remplacé mademoiselle
thiriez blessé au mollet au mollet bon
les molaires été dur pour l'enduro alors
l'enduro du touquet il y avait là-bas 12
sans concurrence je ne vous en citerai
que deux l'un qui s'appelait personnes
et l'autre tout le monde est dans ce
duel entre personnes et tout le monde
est bien ces personnes le studio suédois
qui l'a emporté il faut dire que yamaha
n'avait pas lésiné sur les moyens
pas lésiné sur les moyens en mettant au
point une moto que thierry blancot a pu
découvrir avant le départ bien gardé
cette nouvelle 500 usines
deux raisons 1 son cadre en aluminium à
section carrée utilisé pour la première
fois en tout terrain de son nouveau
moteur à refroidissement liquide
la vedette du touquet 87 perdu au milieu
de mille deux cents concurrents soumises
au jugement de 150 mille passionnés
12h59 on lâche la meute pour trois
heures de course à travers les dunes un
sprint infernal dès le départ 180
km/heure en bout de ligne droite pour
les premiers derrière on relève les
premières victimes
la renommée de l'enduro du touquet une
série de boulets qu'il faut aborder en
tête
dans le cas contraire on y perd toutes
ses chances de victoire on il associe
souvent la machine une série de
difficultés accentuées cette année par
un sable mou et collant une série de
pièges et prouvant sans problème pour
lève personne au guidon de la nouvelle
500 ya ma première participation
première victoire en tête dès le 4e tour
personne l'emportent avec trois minutes
d'avancé sur l'hollandais bande poppel
ktm depuis 81 fiamma n'avait jamais
gagné au touquet du vélo oui foot avec
le tour du haut var et la victoire de
l'allemand de la république fédérale
golds ex champion olympique devant le
français ronan pensec et puis alors en
football et bien ce sont les bus
étrangers qui nous emmène en italie pour
nous faire assister au but des deux
équipes de milan et dans l'assurance
inter voilà exactement avec olivier rey
après une semaine d'interruption en
raison du match de l'équipe nationale
d'italie contre le portugal le
championnat a repris ses droits
aujourd'hui avec l'as roma contre
l'inter de milan
c'est l'équipe romaine qui s'impose
grâce à un but de son joueur vedette le
danois baer green kit vous superbe
reprise de la tête par zynga
le gardien de l'inter de milan autre
match du calcio milan ac contre la
juventus de michel platini
malgré cette alerte c'est la juventus
qui ouvre la marque en deuxième mi temps
par son attaquant serena qui s'y reprend
à deux fois pour tromper galli le
gardien du milan ac la juventus ne
profite pas longtemps de son avantage 2
minutes plus tard le milan ac au sia le
match nul par virdis bonnes performances
ou même de la juventus
au classement naples vainqueur en
déplacement du torino grâce à un but de
jordan au consolide sa place de leader
du classement avec quatre points
d'avancé sur la juventus et voilà vous
avez la grille du de la grille du loto
devrait apparaître alors du côté de
l'espagne a envoyé tous les clubs qui
recevaient ont gagné sauf le match
numéro un cv ils emportèrent bilbao
alors le leader le football club
barcelone joue elle lâche pas le match
en soirée alors dans le championnat
italien voyait une seule victoire à
l'extérieur celle de naples et puis un
deux trois quatre cinq matches nuls et
seulement 2 victoires domicile
bref y'a et roma alors ça n'était pas
évident à trouver sur tous les matches
nuls en italie oui vous avez trouvé deux
ou trois entre 5 et nancy vous qu
dernière peut-être voir le résultat du
tiercé qui se disputait aujourd'hui nous
allons voir ça les résultats avec
les rapports 12 2 6 4 ce tiercé dans
l'ordre cela vous donne 5550 de francs
et puis dans un ordre différent 529 150
pour 5 x 12 2 si c'était le tiercé de ce
dimanche
merci beaucoup pour la météo laurent et
bien ce sera pour une poignée
d'éclaircies ou pour quelques éclaircies
de plus demain le soleil gagne un petit
peu de terrain alors on va toujours
regarder la carte du temps prévu pour
demain parce que le soleil vient du
terrain il ya quand même beaucoup de
nuages sur tout sur tout le quart nord
est du pays des nuages une nuit assez
froide - 3° dans le nord-est -5 degrés
dans le massif central et -2 degrés
du côté de l'aquitaine et une journée
qui restera couvert et surtout le
nord-est avec nuages et quelques chutes
de neige est toujours de la brume dans
la journée sur le reste du pays quelques
éclaircies qu'ils deviendront belle très
belle même près de la méditerranée
puisque sur le languedoc roussillon le
ciel sera bleu sur la provence la côte
d'azur et la corse il y aura à peine
quelques petits nuages
les températures seront stationnaires ou
alors en très très légère pause 2 1 à 6
degrés sur la moitié nord avec 3 degrés
à paris et 4 degrés à lille et de deux
degrés de 3 degrés dans le massif
central jusqu'à 6 7 degrés sur la
méditerranée avec 2,9 degrés 1 9 degrés
à perpignan et à 9 degrés en corse
on termine avec notre agenda demain sera
le lundi 23 février le soleil se lèvera
à 7h47 couchera 18h22 quatre minutes de
soleil qu'en plus nous fêterons les
lazare qui est avec l'udc le patron des
peintres très bien merci beaucoup je
vous rappelle l'information la plus
importante de ce dimanche l'arrestation
des quatre chefs historiques du
mouvement terroriste action directe jean
marc rouillan nathalie ménigon joëlle
aubron georges cipriani ont été arrêtés
hier soir vous voyez leurs photos
communiquer par l'identité judiciaire
c'est jean marc rouillan qui est en haut
à gauche à ses côtés georges cipriani et
puis en bois faisait nathalie ménigon et
joëlle aubron photo le milk et par les
services de police
arrestation groupe et sans effusion de
sang c'était hier soir dans le
département du loiret à une vingtaine de
kilomètres d'orléans dans une ferme
isolée
jean marc rouillan avec le reste du
groupe préparait semble-t-il
l'enlèvement d'une personnalité pour les
jugés dans un tribunal populaire dans
cette ferme isolée beau succès de la
police à 23h15 c'était avec l'autre qui
vous présentera le dernier journal de la
rédaction d'antenne 2 à demain 20 heures
bonsoir merci